so we're continuing our review of the
advance paper we're now going to have a
look at the differential calculus
questions and the first one that we find
is actually the very first question in
the entire paper question one says
differentiate e to the power of three x
squared so what we've got here this
function y equals e to the 3x squared
it's of the form y equals e to the f of
X where our f of X in this case is this
3x squared up in the index there so in
order to differentiate this what you
need to remember is that we're going to
use the chain rule the derivative dy on
DX is equal to first we differentiate
the inside function which in this case
is the index so you'd get f dash X then
you're differentiate at the outside
which is e to the power of some stuff he
is special because when we differentiate
e to the power of something we generally
get e to the power of something whatever
you started with so it's just going to
become e to the power of f of X that's
the outside derivative if that's
something that you struggle to remember
then do recall it is actually found on
the reference sheet so here's the
differential calculus section over here
on the left if you go over here on the
left hand side all the way down here is
the particular version that we're
looking at y equals e to the f of X and
there's the result of the derivative on
the right hand side so if you're
struggling to remember it it is there
but it's faster of course if you can
just do it straight off the top of your
head from memory let's go ahead and do
that now in this case since f of X is 3x
squared f dash X will be 6x I've
multiplied by that index the 2 2 times 3
gives us the 6 and then we reduce the
index by 1 from 2 to 1 where your course
don't need to write X to the power of 1
so there's my F dash X and then I get
left with e to the power of f of X which
was that 3 x squared we saw before and
that lines up with answer C have a look
at question 2 same deal here it's
another chain rule question but this
time with a trigonometric function so
we're going to deal with the inside then
with the outside the inside function
here if I'm differentiating ten of two
X minus 1 he's my inside inside function
2x minus 1 when you differentiate the 2x
you just get the 2 when you're
differentiate that negative 1 you get 0
so here's my inside derivative 2 then i
deal with the outside function which in
this case is tan the derivative of tan
is SEC squared so I've got SEC squared
and then what remains is what the
original inside function was 2x minus 1
that remains unchanged so if you have a
look that lines up with answer D right
so let's have a look at question 3 now
before we get stuck into the solution
for this it's worth remembering some of
the fundamentals of how to differentiate
log functions like the ones that appear
in this particular question so if you
feel quite comfortable with
differentiating log functions then go
ahead and skip this but for everyone
else let's remember that if I'm
differentiating the basic log function
log base a of X or Ln for natural log
then what we get is this very simple
result here 1 over X what that means is
if you're differentiating and using the
chain rule so if you've got log of not
just X but some other function of X that
was a little more complicated then what
you're going to get is the inside
function is derivative multiplied by 1
over the inside function that's what we
get from this original result here so it
would be f dash X there's the inside
derivative multiplied by 1 over f of X
that's the outside derivative and you
can see the parallel from the basic
result to this other result and that
simplifies really neatly because if you
choose the right color you can see that
I can just combine these two terms F
dash X + 1 / f of X into 1 still using
the wrong color you can see that you get
this nice neat fraction here f dash x /
f of X which actually appears on your
reference sheet so if I just scroll down
here a little bit y equals log of f of X
and you can see on the right hand side
there's my F dash on F it's one of the
nicest neatest derivatives to remember
so now if I want to use that for this
particular question let's have a look
I'm doing log of tan X so there in
side the brackets that is my f of X
right there
or should I say that's the f of X as
using the reference sheet I have to be
quite careful here because this f of X
has actually been used in the question
already so I guess I can just call it
the inside function that might be a less
ambiguous way to say it so now when I go
to use the reference sheets result here
f dash X is going to be equal to
derivative of the inside function which
is SEC squared X divided by the inside
function which is 10x now when I have a
look at this it's tempting to look and
say oh I've got it it's Part B answer B
I should say but look carefully that's
not exactly what we've written we've
written SEC squared X on tan X and so
there's that subtle difference here
there's no power appearing here so B is
not the answer that we want I'm in order
to see which of the other answers that
this is going to be closest to an Israel
bit of simplification using our trig
identities so my help if we write this
out a bit longhand SEC squared X divided
by 10x
because SEC squared X is a reciprocal
identity so it's short for 1 over cos
squared if you're one of the people who
has trouble remembering which of the
reciprocal identities refers to the
other ones what do they correspond to
because we don't use them all that
frequently there's kind of a bit of a
cheap hack it's coincidental that it
works but it works so I'm going to show
it to you anyway just in case you
haven't seen it before these are the
three reciprocal identities Kosek SEC
and cot and if you look closely at the
third letter of each one it tells you
what it's the reciprocal of so cosac is
a reciprocal of sine SEC is the
reciprocal of cos and cot is the
reciprocal of tan and like I said it's a
bit of a coincidence that that works out
so it's not that made too much of it but
um it's a nice easy memorable way to
convert from sex squared in this case to
1 over cos squared you know I meant
dividing by tan X which I'm also going
to write in long form because I can use
that to cancel a little bit its sine X
on cos x let's get rid of that division
and take the reciprocal of the second
fraction so I'm getting one over cos
squared x cos x on sine X so this now
you can start to see where the
simplification is going to happen
let's move this guy of the way when I
have a look at this line here I can do
some canceling that cos X on the top is
going to cancel with one of the COS X's
on the denominator that leaves us with 1
over in fact I'm going to leave them as
two separate fractions 1 over cos x
times 1 over sine X now when you just
glance up to those solutions that are
offered again this is none of the
options that's there unless we go back
to our reciprocal identity so 1 over cos
that is equal to SEC and 1 over sine is
equal to cosec and you can see that
gives us answer C as our solution now I
will just quickly pause and notice that
you can actually solve this in a
different way
I wouldn't recommend doing this in the
exam because this way as usually is
longer but it's always good to know
there's multiple paths through a
question and part of what we are
actually assessing for is your ability
to know what the different parts are and
be able to use the most appropriate or
the most efficient one so let me just
show you one other way to do this that
in another question might actually be
more useful for you before jumping into
the differentiation go to f dash x
equals blah blah blah what I'm going to
do is look at f of X first
so that's log of 10x I'm gonna write
this solution in a different color just
so you can distinguish the two now if I
have a look at log of tan X before I
start differentiating I can actually
simplify this a bit further or at least
write it in a different form
that might mean I don't have to deal
with such a complex use of the chain
rule so I'm going to write this as log
of sine X on cos x so we saw before now
you might think why do I do this now
well it's because one of the log rules
we know is when you're dividing inside
the log what that's equivalent to is
subtracting logs so log of sine X
takeaway log of cos x now if this was
not something that was immediately
apparent to you in this question it was
no penalty but in other questions you
are going to need to you
use those log laws they weren't the
focus of this question but they kind of
linger in the background there and just
like with index laws you kind of need to
be very confident and fluent in those so
that you can then concentrate on the
calculus in these questions so if that
was not a result you didn't you saw
immediately don't worry about it but let
me show you how you can now use it this
is the way that I've written f of X so
now I'm going to begin differentiating
and it's the use of this same result
that we had before
inside derivative over the inside
function so what's the inside derivative
for log of sine X it's going to be the
derivative of sine X which is cos x
divided by the inside function which is
sine X so that's this guy over here then
I subtract because that is the operation
between them and I repeat it for this
second function so takeaway log of cos x
when I differentiate that here's the
inside derivative minus sine X watch for
the plus and minus signs there and then
I divide by the inside function which in
this case is cos X all right so what we
got here cos x over sine X I'm just
gonna leave that for one moment I will
take that double negative and I'll say
well that's a plus and I'll write it as
sine x over cos x and now I've got two
functions without or two fractions
rather with different denominators so I
need to get a common denominator so they
can actually combine these two the
common denominator I'm going to use here
is not sine X or cos x but sine x times
cos x so if I multiply this first
fraction by cos x over cos X I will get
cos squared X over sine X cos x so I
haven't changed that fraction I've just
multiplied it by cos over cos and for
the second fraction to get the common
denominator
I'll multiplied by sine over sine so
that gives me sine squared x over now
I've got sine x cos x my denominators in
our matching so I've got common
denominators which means I can combine
these two fractions into one I've got
cos squared plus sine squared or divided
by this sine X
common denominator that I saw before if
you have a look at this closely con
squared plus sine squared this is an
identity that we learned last year close
squared X plus sine squared X no matter
what the value of x is you can go ahead
and test it on your calculator it's
always equal to 1
so that's something we actually get from
Pythagoras's theorem this is why this is
often called the Pythagorean identity so
you can go back to the unit circle if
you want to understand why this identity
works out and how come it becomes so
simple that's divided by the sine x cos
x that we got as our common denominator
and from this point you can see this
leads us to where our working was before
now like I said this is probably not the
best way to solve this particular
problems why I didn't show you this
solution first but it is another path
and often the only way that you can
progress through a particular question
when it's dealing with logs is to use
some of these log laws that I just
showed you like like this one here
converting a single log and breaking it
into two so if one of the lessons that
you want to learn out from this is to
revise your log walls then hopefully
that's useful for you